e
e e
time being 1:15 we will speak to uh
commissioner Bon Court of the insurance
department whose Pages start at 295
that's right in
house welcome commissioner thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is DJ beton Court I
have the pleasure of serving as the
commissioner of the New Hampshire
insurance department it is nice to be
back with you as a legislator in a
former legislator in what I call
long-term recovery I appreciate the fact
that you've got a big job to do and so I
don't have any Grand presentation for
you this morning I'm going to hit some
of the highlights and then we can take
this in whatever direction that you
would like so in terms of the
Department's budget you will see in the
documents in front of you that our total
budget is approximately $15.5 million we
are a self-funded agency uh we get the
funding for the Department via an
assessment of all of the insurance
companies that are doing business in the
state of New Hampshire that is
calculated out as a PR share of the
total written premium that they write in
New Hampshire so obviously some of those
companies are being assessed more than
others what is the total do you know I'm
sorry what is that total amount of
premiums in New Hampshire the total
amount of premiums written it's over 8
billion 8 billion okay 8 billion and if
that sounds like a big number and it is
I do appreciate the fact that New
Hampshire represents less than one half
of 1% of the total written premium in
the United States of
America so we regulate a very lucrative
industry to be sure uh it also speaks to
the regulatory attitude that we take in
the sense that we really do try to form
close collaborative relationships with
industry because we just don't have the
leverage uh to be adversarial or
heavy-handed in how we approach our
regulatory uh duties because we're an
awfully small part of that market we
represent a very small share of the
market but I think our team does a
phenomenal job so in any event that is
the total budget for the Department that
is how it is raised I know that you want
to talk and focus on positions so I'll
hit upon that so we have 88 authorized
positions we currently have eight vacant
as you may recall this past late summer
or early fall Governor cunu asked All
State agencies to go through an exercise
by which I think he had asked for us to
put forward a budget that reflected a 4%
reduction in expenditures we went
through that process again despite the
fact that none of that hard work is of
benefit to you and the Cent
challenge that you all are going through
I wish it could be different but
unfortunately it is not but nevertheless
as a result of that exercise we unfunded
three uh full-time positions so we
certainly tried to carry forward the
spirit of what governor C was asking
everybody to do at that
time so those are the positions you'll
see that some of the lines have gone up
others have gone down I am very
attentive to what the assessment is for
carriers the insurance industry at
present is going through what we call a
hard market and so we do not want to do
anything that's going to exacerbate what
are some of the challenges in the
insurance Market at present and so we've
tried to really strike a balance uh
between having the resources that we
need again while not overburdening
industry I would note that last year we
essentially what it amounts to is a re
debate um if I might just depart for a
second introduce you to my team here
I've got Jennifer Smith who is our
legislative director Jason Dexter who is
our assistant commissioner Ted Perkins
who is our business director and Amy
doam who is our tax unit director I
apologize for not introducing them
earlier um integral members of my team I
think I just made everybody a director
commissioner I may have just promoted
some people on the spot here but the
salaries will stay the same
let me let me show you um but in any
event because of how we managed our
budget we were able to as I've said what
basically amounts to a rebate back to
Industry last year of about 2.6 million
so we really did budget very very
carefully how that rebate works and Amy
can get into the details of it is it is
a credit towards their next year's
assessment so the assessment for them
coming up is going to be $2.6 million
less no individual ual companies going
to reap any significant windfall of that
but again it is helpful and it certainly
sets hopefully a tone that we are here
to work collaboratively with industry
and help them work through what is a
difficult time so do you mean you're
rebating 26 million of what you
collected in fiscal year
24 I think that's right yep yes okay and
did you collect in fiscal year 24 12.4
million yes sir okay so you actually
only used about
10 oh I see oh so you're budgeted 15
that's right right minus 2.6 that
becomes this
12.4 I got it thank you very much that's
right so again that hopefully speaks to
the fact that we are very respons POS
with how we budget we are attentive to
how we spend we do not waste but
obviously we have a mission given to us
by the state we take that mission very
very seriously so those are the big
highlights for me Mr chairman and as
I've said we can go in whatever
Direction you'd like yeah I think we
we'll go sort of Page by Page or just
have questions um let me just start on
this bottom line you said you remove
three positions so so should the 88 be
85 so we unfund funded three positions
they're still authorized but they're
unfunded I
see but if we wanted to we could
unauthorize them
or okay um you can tell us the position
numbers right y we do at some point yeah
that is that in the materials we
provided them if not we can certainly
get that to you Mr J okay yep no problem
at all okay right
yeah all right uh representative
Ms thank you Mr chair thank you for
coming in good to see you again I'm I'm
I'm just I'm trying
to understand this rebate that you just
described so
um that rebate it was $2.6 Million it
was it was offered or was given to
Industry during fiscal year
24 no
reduce their balance due that they owe
on their next assessment so we'll take
the authorized budget let's say 5.5
million and if there's a rebate or
refund that we didn't use the money
it'll come off what we collect for the
coming but why don't but I don't see
that I mean what I what I see is there's
an increase there's an increase in in in
expenses and revenue from fiscal year
for a fiscal year 25 of 2.6
million roughly 2.6 million he is
speaking to the Personnel lines that the
Personnel lines from the previous budget
to this budget have gone up so I could
speak to the the policy driver behind
that so when I came back to state
government in 2017 I was having
conversations with insurance
Commissioners at that time at that time
it was commissioner savini followed by
commissioner Elias followed by
commissioner nicolopoulos and the one
thing they all said very consistently
was we need to get very serious about
succession planning in this department
we are on the older side of the scale in
terms of age and Personnel we've got to
get serious about this um my department
is uh chalk full of subject matter
experts uh they are subject matter
experts in some facet of insurance such
that anytime an issue comes up I'm going
to have somebody in that building that's
going to be able to address that
specific issue but we over the past
couple of years actually got serious
about succession planning and so we
started to fill some positions uh that
had not been filled before and the idea
being that before this institutional
knowledge this expertise leaves the
building will'll have an opportunity for
the Next Generation to be able to learn
and train and get experience from those
folks uh again because of the subject
matter expertise that is needed in our
department we can't just take anybody
off the street and put them into some of
these positions we need people who have
a high degree of experience in whatever
unit we're talking about here and so
representative I think what you're
speaking to is yes the Personnel line is
going up because we've started to fill
some of those positions but in terms of
the uh rebate from the last fiscal year
I think Amy can speak specifically about
that I'm just trying to reconcile
what I what I think I heard and I and
and I think you confirmed that it's a
rebate that was offered
in that will that that will reduce the
um the the Assessments in FY 15 uh 25
with what representative Maguire asked
which is the so the two that that the
2.6 came off of the number in
2024 I understand what he's saying to
you yeah so maybe I'll try let me try to
answer and you tell me if I'm wrong
which is I believe our budget two years
ago had similar numbers to what you see
in the fy2 column in the FY 24 column so
two years ago we gave them a budget said
15 million right and uh so that's what
they collected from all the insurance
companies right but they ended up
actually spending the 12 point whatever
right so now they're giving a credit to
the insurance companies of the
difference
yes and and they may this year spend
less than the 15 and therefore there'll
be yet another credit to I will not make
a commitment on what that number will be
but yes we budget very tight absolutely
I guess that's the thing I'm struggling
with is that if the there's so there's a
so we know that there's 2.6 million
that's going to be given to the
companies so why isn't that 2.6
reduction reflected in the numbers for
25 I'm guessing because in the meantime
they may have hired a few people that's
right and and they may have given some
raises right and benefit costs went up a
little and things like that right so so
we don't know that this year they'll
they'll be 2.6 short again it might be
one it might be some other numers right
so correct Mr chairman you have to make
assumptions that you know potentially
you fill every position you don't know
what step they're going to come in at
all of those types of things so you've
got to to budget assuming that you're
going to be at full capacity and that
you're going to expend every line which
again in reality has never happened um
but you have to assume that and then to
your point Mr chair when you get to the
end uh you see what you didn't spend and
at the end of the day it's not our money
it's the the company's money and so My
Philosophy is you give that money
back and the hope is of course is that
that benefit will trickle down to the
consumer in the form of their being able
to get if not reduced premiums at least
stabilized premiums do you know how many
people work in an insurance industry in
in New Hampshire oh boy that's a tough
question to answer because it depends on
how you define it so are you're talking
about all of The Producers which is to
say all of the independent agents all of
the Brokers and things of that nature
that's a tough number to pin
down plus then you've got to determine
what do you consider to be doing
business in New Hampshire I mean we've
got a lot of producers who live in other
states but are authorized to write
business in New Hampshire you know do
you include them or not um it's a lot I
mean let me ask it a different way sure
of the 8 billion in premiums how much is
paid out in
claims versus how much is expense
it's a great question I don't know we
could try to track that down for you
yeah I'd be curious I what's their
profit margin is it 10% is you know we'
got about represent month so just try to
close the door on this issue so this
whole business of you know rebates Etc
that only affects the FY 2425 bium
doesn't have any impact on
2627 right because we don't know what
the refund will be yet okay
till after 30 I think I think I get
it okay I
mean I guess I'm I'm I have a hard time
finding fault here because of the8
billion do in premiums the cost of this
regulation is like 0 2% or less right so
it's it's a very tiny number in the
overall scheme of Y right exactly right
exactly right um any other we have other
question yeah represent people are you
paging
through oh yeah go ahead representative
people well I mean I actually have a
couple of questions so just because we
we've been looking at it issues on uh
page
295 027 transfers to oit I see that's
going up is I just was curious what's
happening
there you don't know they tell us what
the amount is and we cut the check you
have in beds we do we have two in beds
in the so it's okay I mean any other so
this is more Personnel type stuff not
moving to the cloud and that would be my
assumption all right so you're not sure
okay so then the next thing is on page
297 um I see under the financial
examination division are those the
positions that you unfunded or do you
have or maybe I'm reading this wrong I'm
looking at uh
estimates
yeah let me see zeros sure so let me try
to answer that and maybe I'll get it if
not it's okay you can clarify so off the
top of my head the three positions that
were unfunded one was a position in our
fraud division the other was in fact in
the Property and Casualty examiner
Division and the other was in our tax
unit and then there was one was that
also Jason in the life and health
examiner so there so of the four
positions that we unfunded two of them
are in the examiner realm one in
Property and Casualty the other in life
and health and then as I said the other
two were a fraud position and a position
in our tax
unit and so I would assume that's
reflected in the line that she's
referring to yeah the the two here on
page 297 got moved to page
296 right so you see 68 became 70 on
page 296 and two got fewer on page
29 my main concern is that you still
have what you think is adequate coverage
for fraud and examination within the
department yes fraud absolutely they are
hitting record marks in terms of
referrals to the various entities that
will actually do the prosecution so our
fraud division will work with County
attorneys they'll work with the Attorney
General's office they'll work with the
US attorney's office they do a
phenomenal job they basically do all or
most of the invest investigatory work
and they'll package that case up that it
is ready to go in the event that a
prosecutor in one of those offices
determines to move forward with it so
I'm very confident that we're not going
to uh miss a step with regard to fraud
that position has been vacant for a very
very long time uh in terms of
examination I think we're in great shape
there too we always have the option to
bring in outside contractors uh to
supplement the work of our examiners and
the cost of using those outside
contractors is baked into the cost of
the exam itself which is directly build
to the company that is being examined
how that work as far as the uh
examination of the insurance companies
do you go in on like an annual bait or
just talk to us a little bit about that
whole issue so it depends we do a number
of different types of examinations so we
do have statutory requirements to
examine certain entities for certain
things on a set time schedule for
example every company in New Hampshire I
think within a five or 10 year span has
to go through a financial examination
where our financial regulation division
goes in and ensures that the companies
are solvent and there's a lot that goes
into that uh that team is uh does a
great job I affectionately call them our
math nerds um there's a lot that goes
into that but obviously it goes to the
heart of our consumer protection mission
in the sense that if a company's not
solvent or if it's going bankrupt it's
awfully hard for them to pay claims in
other
cases um what will happen
is our consumer division will begin to
hear from consumers about a problem that
they're having with a particular company
and our consumer division uh works very
closely with our Market conduct teams
and so when we start to see a trend
developing particular problem related to
a particular company that will trigger
one of those teams saying it's time to
go in to do an exam that takes a look at
what's happening here to see if there is
a systematic problem that is taking
place here and by problem we mean uh
something that is not in compliance with
the rule or the law and so that will
drive an examination as well so a couple
of different ways that we'll do it some
of them are on a set schedule others are
driven by whatever the scenario is
that's playing itself out on the
ground representative Lehman then
representative mik thank you Mr chairman
so turning to page 298 getting back into
the U employment
compensation area and you've got
um about
$400,000 if you look at total
funds on the state flexibility cycle
two um that has all gone away apparently
if you carry it right across and the
positions have gone away way I guess so
if you look at that and adding that to
the $12
million and then looking at what you're
looking for $15 million in this coming
year it seems like your overall budget
has gone up substantially because you're
not carrying a lot of those expense
numbers into 26 and 27 so I would assume
you'd be closer to more like 13 million
for per year for 26 and 27 versus 15 I'm
just
curious what your thoughts are to that
sure well what I would say is I think
part of that is driven by the fact that
last budget we had a 12% increase in
terms of what we were going to pay state
employees so I think that plays
certainly a part in that as well um what
you see here in terms of what we're
presenting to you again reflects that 4%
reduction that we were asked to make
last summer in Fall we did move some
numbers around based off of what our
needs were and what we foresaw as being
the needs over the course of the next
bium but any other thoughts on that team
to go deeper
Jason come on
up if you are looking at the um the the
393,000 which is in consultant line Y
Flex Grant we didn't use any of that or
New Hampshire insurance department
employees those were all consultant
contracts that we did rfps we brought in
consultants and we paid those funds out
and then that Grant has been
closed I completely understand that I'm
just wonder if you look at the bottom
line for your entire department it's $12
million the last accurate figure for 24
and yet in 26 and
27 you're looking for more than 15
million and is is that also assuming the
4% cut is that not included in the 15 or
is it included in the $15
million so that 15 as I understand it is
we were told to reduce four and then
certain things went up like
benefits
and that's after that number is after us
not funding the three positions three
positions or four positions we've heard
four positions
I heard
three
exam the budget shows four
positions nor normas okay the fourth it
would be was a
temporary uh
position that was Amy's old position we
brought her back temporarily to help get
Amy up to speed
month so um I I have I have three three
questions I'd like to ask the the first
is
um um do you get any revenue does your
do you have oversight for health
insurance as well we do but I always
preface this by saying well we have
oversight over represents approximately
30% of the health insurance
Market in New Hampshire we do not
oversee the two government programs
Medicare Medicaid okay and we do not
oversee self-funded right SL Arisa
Arrangements that obviously is overseen
by the federal government the US
Department of Labor so but so the all
fully insured health insurance is your
your responsibility individual small
group and large group markets yes okay
um and then um the the appraisal um the
appraisal fees that you um assess those
companies when's the last time those
were Chang those were
updated Ral fees he talking about the
assessment the administrative assessment
to theany the you know your the the fee
that you charged to get all the revenue
the agency income when when was talking
about the IP rate insurance premium tax
rate yeah when was that when the last
time that was changed sorry I got
tripped up on the I believe the
legislature revised the insurance
premium tax rate in
20 2010 somewhere in that neighborhood
okay my understanding is that the
motivation at the time was to lower the
rates in the hopes that we would attract
more insurance companies to New
Hampshire not just to write in New
Hampshire but to actually domesticate in
New Hampshire okay I don't know how
that's gone other than to say we've got
a very competitive market so we do like
that okay and then the third and final
question for this round um is um that
income that you receive uh
from um you know these companies the
agency the agency income that you're
reporting is is that um restricted to
for use only by you or can that be used
for other purposes as well so the
insurance premium tax revenue all goes
to the general fund the general fund
gets all of that in terms of fines again
that and fees that all goes to the
general fund I don't know that we retain
anything anything the administrative
assessment okay the administrative
assessments about it so it all goes to
the general fund it's not um it's not uh
what's the what's the term it's not
burdened okay one of the items that we
included in our house bill 2 submission
that was left on The Cutting Room floor
was to try to retain a certain portion
of the fees that uh excuse me of the
fines that our enforcement division
brings in to offset the cost of that
division our thought process there was
that we had filled a position in
enforcement to try to again keep the
assessment as low as we possibly can
while also meeting the needs of the
department by letting us hang on to some
of those dollars we could offset the
cost of that let some of the Bad actors
um keep the costs under control for
everyone else it didn't end up making it
into the governor's proposed budget but
that was the only discussion that we've
had in terms
of the department hanging on to anything
other than the assessment which is used
to fund our
operations
okay so the insurance
Revenue to the uh I guess to the general
fund is 166 million a year
something oh something like that oh
plus no I guess that's
it
um am I oh wait a minute Insurance
yeah am I looking at the right page
actually this kind of goes with what
you're doing I don't quite understand
what your source of funds is so could
you just like spell it out because you
referred funds in terms of how the
department is funded yeah so again we
will assess all of the insurance
companies who are doing business in the
state of New Hampshire those will
include companies that you see
advertised on television to some of the
smaller ones that you wouldn't even know
existed until perhaps your agent made
you aware that they were there and could
provide you with the particular kind of
coverage that you need so on a per
capita basis of what they write in New
Hampshire it goes through a formula and
that is what their assessment is so
fundamentally that's how it works Amy do
you want to add some meat to those bones
yeah so there's uh close to, 1300 com
licensed companies in the state that get
the
assessment based on the amount of
Premium that they write
here and we we send out that assessment
once a year in
September and so when we were just
talking about your crediting back 2.6
million that wouldn't be money that
otherwise could have gone to the general
fund or or because that okay and then
the fine part is what goes to the
general fund
gotcha is this fines or is it a
tax both okay both so the insurance
premium tax right into the general fund
is that
2% on the health it is but for property
casualty it's
1.25% okay we've got two different rates
depending on the line of business thank
you um so insurance premium tax all
right into the general fund fines that
we assess companies whether they be
enforcement fines whether they be fines
that generate from a market conduct exam
again all of that goes into the general
fund okay I think representative wer had
us
hand microphone
some years ago I was involved with a
study committee where the the
Independent Auto Repair people were
coming in complaining about the rates
they were getting uh somebody has a
damage to a vehicle if they go to the
Chevy dealer because it's a Chevrolet
the insurance company pays much higher
rate than if they go to their friend
down the street he wouldn't get the same
money for doing the same repair was the
complaint and they also argued that the
insurance
division didn't have skilled people that
uh knew how to assess damages is that
still the case you say you got a lot of
subject matter experts so yeah I think
we've got the experts to certainly be
able to determine damages within what
the law dictates what we hear a lot from
the shops basically amounts to the fact
that they don't like the negotiated
rates they're at an impass in terms of
what they're negotiating for rates
between them and the insurance company
we don't get involved in those
negotiations typically there are
exceptions to every rule you may have
seen that I did get involved with the
contract uh negotiation between St
Joseph's Hospital down in Nashua and
Anthem not all that long ago there was a
very specific set of circumstances that
motivated me to do that but in general
we allow the parties to negotiate out
those details on their own we don't get
involved in the Contracting process
so I wonder if that's still the truth
that if I have my Chevrolet in an
accident and I go to the Chevy dealer
the insurance company will pay him more
for the same repair than my friend down
the street that you know gets it and it
was
some initial
for a part that was as good as new or
something I can't remember but then some
company went into business using those
same initials sure so when they said you
know like new you remember what those
there were all nuances that go into that
in terms of what is negotiated out in
the contract I think what you might be
referring to are aftermarket parts and
the use of those aftermarket parts and
all of that we could certainly bring in
our Property and Casualty team that
could get into all of the Gory details
of how all of that works all right I'm
just wondering if you're still getting
many complaints from these independent
repair places it iies it does vary you
know to kind of my ear they've certainly
not gone up I think it pretty stable one
particular repair guy that stirred up
everything that would indeed be the case
and um he has since sold his shop and
you wouldn't believe the nose dive that
the complaint our consumer division has
received in terms of uh a decrease in
complaints it was
extraordinary thank you represent Ms
thank you um and and again forgive me
for my uh my my uh math issues here um
so I think I heard you say earlier that
there's about eight billion dollar worth
of um coverage out premium premium out
there we're we're assessing a a tax of
either 1.25 or
2% if you do that
math um that generates if I'm doing it
right generates about just assuming that
everything is property and casually I
know that's not the case that generates
$100
million so is is is that the total
amount of money that's being generated
and so only a portion of it is what
we're seeing here I guess I'm trying to
understand is the total amount that's
being
generated by these taxes is it $15
million or is it something else let me
try representative mon so re the revenue
from those taxes is in the back of house
bill one okay it's just like business
taxes meals and rooms tax tobacco tax
all those kind of things there's a line
that says
Insurance 166 million okay yeah so
that's on page it's unnumbered but
but it's a big number yeah this part the
15 million is simply their particular
operations
and they and they charge you know that
much just for that but this big number
is is a tax on insurance right but the
15 million that we're seeing here is
part is coming out of that 166 million
no
no okay I'm really conf it's a separate
think of it this way I'll try to you're
doing a very good job Mr Jim I'll try to
carry on in your spirit here um it's a
separate expense so put simply there are
two different obligations the company
has to pay the first is their insurance
premium tax obligation that's your one
in change and then your 2% obligation
that's one piece of it and again all of
that goes into the general fund then
there is the assessment which funds the
department and that's how we are able to
operate and exist so what is the
assessment so the assessment again is a
calculation based off of the prata share
of the premium that you write in New
Hampshire and so again and I'm going to
just throw out some companies that
you'll know you know Anthem is our
largest health insurance carrier in New
Hampshire so obviously their obligation
is going to be higher than say a smaller
lesser known health insurance company
you know same as it would be if you were
talking about a Geico or an all state on
the property and Casualty side versus a
company again you wouldn't even be aware
existed were it not for the fact that
your independent agent knew of them and
knew that they could provide you with
coverage and enfor but what is the rate
of the
assessment it's a prog of share
calculation that's why as he mentioned
of of the of the premium tax yes of the
amount of Premium of the amount of
Premium written not the premium tax the
amount of Premium written and I think
that's all prescribed right in statute
so so in a sense they take the number in
the budget they H they estimate how much
premium is going to be written they
divide and that's the that's the tax
rate right so so they they take the 15
million in the budget they take the 8
billion that they estimate is going to
be the amount of premiums in the year
they divide and get 0 2% and then they
charge everybody 0
2% okay
and then at the end of the year they say
oh we didn't really spend 15 we spent 12
therefore you have a credit for next
year right that's right yes and and if I
could Mr chairman the
problemes and all of fearness to
representative muns um generally we get
a good handout from all the different
agencies and you guys have been good at
this in the past but especially to help
our newer members that gives a better
explan a of everything going on but as
far as the insurance premium tax it's
like my business pays that because the
insurance company collects it from me
and then sends it to the state but so
that's how that works so it does cost
the consumers in the state a lot of
money because they're winding up paying
that fee through the insurance premium
tax okay anyway I will certainly make a
note to do handouts in the future I was
keeping an eye on the line for supplies
but we can certainly uh put a
presentation for you in the future so
that you can have that hopefully you'll
make this process a little EAS represent
of evil all right so I have a question
so I'm sort of uh interested in the um
staff position you said was left on The
Cutting Room floor so I'm interested in
your estimates uh return on investment
for having another enforcement
person um number one and whether the
enforcement person could have been paid
out of the assessment rather than out of
the fines because the fines are things
that go into the general fund sure so it
wasn't a position that was left on The
Cutting Room floor rather what we
proposed was to account for the fact
that that position will be accounted for
in the ass there won't be as much of a
rebate going back by virtue of the fact
that we filled that position so it's
still going to be paid for via the
assessment I just tried to get creative
and filling the position and keeping the
assessment low or as low as we could
make it okay well I I'm just interested
in the consumer protection part of the
business so I I was I just wanted to
make sure you're fully staffed no
absolutely we're fully staffed and and
representative to your point the ROI
aspect of that is a big deal to me we
are going through as an organization a
strategic planning process and I have
made it very clear to the units that got
positions that they had asked for or had
positioned filled that they had asked
for okay that's fine but you're going to
need to come back to me and tell me how
what the return on that was have we been
able to process things faster have we
been able to take on a greater uh
workload um are we generating more
revenue for the general fund as a result
of this we're going to be scrutinizing
that very very carefully over the course
of the next year to year and a
half do you know how those two tax rates
compared to other New England states so
I'm asked this all the time you know
we're pretty low I I can't there may be
some that are lower I know there are a
lot that are higher I can tell you that
where exactly we fall Amy can I can
speak to that um we are on the low side
but we have a retaliatory tax provision
and what that means is we can collect
the higher of the company state of
domicile rate or the New Hampshire rate
so it's one of those situations where
um when some states do some things that
we wouldn't ordinarily do we get some of
the benefit of that when California and
New York want to raise their taxes
because of that provision we make out
pretty well on that we don't have to
touch our tax rate so so we give them an
incentive to move their headquarters to
New Hampshire is that right
yeah that is certainly The Hope okay I
like that all right anybody else else
did I see a hand Mr chairman before you
let us go I did just want to give you a
quick heads up go ahead so another item
that we had originally included in our
house bill to was a proposed program
called the granite state home resiliency
and mitigation fund uh as a result of
some conversations that we had had with
the leadership both in the house and the
Senate they asked us to go through a
different process to have that proposal
vetted and so that currently sits with
the house Commerce Committee they're
working through the policy of it just
very quickly I'll describe to you the
program right now and representative
muns knows this very well he had me down
in his district this past summer I was
hearing from his constituents about the
challenges that they're facing in terms
of being able to access affordable
homeowners insurance coverage as I
mentioned at the outset industry is
going through what we would call a hard
Market just very quickly um the industry
is dealing with a lot of losses at the
moment some of that is economic driven
things like that you're aware of things
like inflation and um inflation and
interest rates the cost of technology
and a lot of that technology is great
it's all safety oriented we want people
to be as safe as possible in their homes
and in their vehicles but that
technology is expensive and so when it
breaks or when you need the expertise to
install or repair it that's obviously
more expensive but the other huge driver
of the hard market right now are huge
cat atrophic weather events the
Hurricanes that Wipe Out the State of
Florida the Gulf Coast the Carolinas the
horrific wildfires that you saw out in
California that hit one of the most
expensive property markets in the
world those are huge losses and so when
the companies are experiencing that type
of financial difficulty what they'll do
is more carefully manage their risk
exposure and so you'll see that in form
in the form of higher premiums or they
will withdraw from certain markets in
some cases or they'll try to get
creative as to where they're going to
write and that's a huge problem down in
our Sea Coast Area and we're working
aggressively through that none of us has
the ability to control the weather I
know all of us wishes that we could but
one of the things that some states have
done and that we're trying to bring to
New Hampshire is to create a grant
program that allows for homeowners to
apply into that Grant to do something
some sort of improvement or enhancement
of their home or the property and the
eligibility criteria of those projects
is all geared toward a better
positioning the consumer in the
underwriting process so that the hope is
that again we will not see some folks
being non-renewed the way that we are at
present um or we will see their premiums
stabilize or come
down so the lowest hanging fruit that we
think uh this this program could help
Advance are the big old oak tree or pine
tree that's kind of sort of hanging over
the house it's a big tree it's expensive
to have it removed somewhere in the
neighborhood my parents just went
through it it cost them about
$4,000 not everybody has the ability to
Fork out
$4,000 to get that tree addressed but if
they were it would be a huge difference
for them in terms of underwriting for
their homeowners insurance policy
because obviously that tree presents a
significant risk to the home and so what
we proposed was to retain a million
dollars of the IP put it into that fund
and allow consumers to apply in we have
a means test in there so that we are
really addressing the granted Staters
who could most benefit from that the
grants would be capped at
$10,000 so if the big issue for that
home was a roof typically roofs are
going to cost more than $10,000 to
repair but we would at least be able to
kick in the first 10,000 for them first
come first Ser first come first serve
basis once the million dollar is
expended that's it for the year uh so in
a nutshell that's how it would work
again Commerce is vetting the policy of
it my hope is that it would come over to
you all for examination look I've sat in
your chairs before Lord knows
representative wer and I were in a
really bad spot back in 2011 I
appreciate the fact fact that you've got
to think very carefully and scrutinize
every dollar that you've got and how you
want to spend it if in the event it is
your determination that the million
dollars is better spent elsewhere than
for this program I understand I would
just say one last pitch for the program
we talk a lot about housing and what we
can do for housing in New Hampshire I
would ask you to bear in mind that you
cannot get a mortgage to buy a home
unless you have homeowners insurance
coverage and so for firsttime home
buyers that insurance is a is a burden
it's a pretty significant financial
burden so to the extent that we can
leverage that million to help not only
the new homeowners but everybody but I
think in terms of impact it would
certainly be helpful to them uh bear
that in mind as well that all being said
if you determine that the dollars are
better spent elsewhere what I would ask
you to consider is to authorize the
program not fund the program reason
being is because we are hearing that
there is great interest in Washington
for these types of programs and there is
a real possibility that the federal
government will make dollars available
to either um motivate states to create
programs such as this or to fund the
programs that they currently have in
place and so what I would ask is again
I'd really like to see the program go
forward with the funding but if not give
us the ability to have the vehicle ready
to go so that in the event EV that
Washington makes those dollars available
we've we've got the structure in the
program ready to go that we can just
drop those dollars into and head out um
no increase in taxes no increase in the
assessment for this program no
additional staff for this
program as I've said the the highlight
of it is for your purposes is the the
million dollars in IP that we would use
to fund it so let me ask a question
about this
so you give the example of tree falls on
house causes a claim okay um and
therefore if the program was in place
fewer trees would fall on the house
fewer claims right that's right okay
um is the benefit of fewer claims
strictly to the person that owns the
house I mean does the when somebody buys
insurance on that house do they send
somebody out there and say oh tree
therefore premium yep right an appraiser
will come out an underwriter will come
out and do that work right and and and
whereas the house next door no tree
premium right or is it more that in New
Hampshire uh there's 4,000 houses
damaged by trees therefore in New
Hampshire insurance is that much more
expensive than otherwise right so each
property needs to be individually
underwritten okay so that it really is
within a again setting aside Financial
capacity of the individual it really is
within the control of the property owner
to do as much as they possibly can to
mitigate some of the risk that's
assessed within that underwriting
process look if you're representative Ms
and his constituents you can't change
the fact that you're living closer to
the Atlantic Ocean than I am in
Salem that is outside of your control
but again in those instances where
you've got a variable that you can
control such as the viig tree or the
fact that the roof needs to be replaced
or you can do some things to fortify the
foundation of your property as an
example that will make it more resilient
to flood uh type situations that is
within your control those would be the
types of things that the program would
seek to be able to assist the consumer
with so again they'd Faire better in
that underwriting process I couldn't I
couldn't get um homeowners insurance um
this year not because I was in a flood
plane but because lived a half mile from
the from the ocean and the insurer was
concerned about wind
damage that was we obviously to someone
else or yeah we found another we found
another carrier but um um it was more
expensive and the deductible went way up
right okay so the state of Alabama was
actually the first state in the country
to put this program forward and um so
they created the model for the rest of
us and it's I joke it's my favorite kind
of r and D rip off and duplicate uh but
as we bring it to New Hampshire we have
tried to New Hampshire eyes the program
because we don't have the same types of
weather risks in New Hampshire that you
do in the Gulf Coast if you're in the
Gulf Coast you're obviously very worried
about the wind damage that comes from
hurricanes or or flood threats that come
from those hurricanes in New Hampshire
we've got predominantly flood issues
we've got Micro Burst issues uh just
this past summer we had a Micro Burst
that did one heck of a lot of damage out
Milford it was a horrible situation so
our program is geared towards those
types of things so we're not so much
worried about strapping of roofs and
fortifying walls to those hurricane
forced winds we're focused on those
things like again fortifying the base of
the property to guard against flood to
the greatest extent possible the wind
and Micro Burst issues again dealing
with those trees addressing the roof
we've really tried to make it specific
to the actual experience that we have in
New Hampshire so I got to say from my
point of view you gave me the wrong
answer to this question because I don't
see why it's the responsibility of
people in Epsom to help people in
Hampton get get insurance right I mean
they get to live near the ocean and I
don't right so it's
like I don't see it no I don't see it so
much that way Mr chairman because
again it's the purview of the individual
property owner to talk with the company
and say okay where is my property
running a foul of your your underwriting
guidelines and the individuals say well
sir you've got this big dead oak tree
and if you address that big dead oak
tree you'd Faire better so the
individual can apply into the grant get
that oak tree dealt with and and fair
better as an individual property owner
I think where I may have thrown off
who's paying the grant though it would
come from the
IP the insurance premium from the
general fund yeah yeah so that's me
sure so
anyways we I will be uh telling our
local police chief to keep an eye out
for you and keep you off the beach yeah
yeah
okay all right representative cambr
thank you Mr chair uh would it be means
tested in any way
yes it is means tested and uh the owner
would have to provide an estimate first
and you would not you said it would go
up to
$10,000 but we would would you typically
match half of what it would cost or
would you if say the new roof only cost
99,900 would you give them the full
amount no nobody's nobody's making a
profit we've got a lot of different
Provisions in there that hold the
contractors accountable uh you know to
the extent that the job is quoted at
5,000 and only cost
four uh it it's so to the extent that
it's a bigger project and some of those
funds have to be front loaded and again
we worked very closely with the Home
Builders Association to understand
nuances of this thing some of it would
need to be front loaded for example if
it was a new roof the contractor would
obviously have to pay for those
materials up front but they're not going
to get the full amount of whatever the
total cost of the project is up to that
$10,000 until the project is done
represent W did
you we've only got about 30 some working
days cut a few hundred million I get it
from the budget we're not making any
progress here he's self-funded yeah yeah
there's no money to be gotten here I'm
surprised we're spending this much time
on it well it's just our schedule didn't
put the next the next person's coming in
five minutes
so and we we like to talk all right
representative eel for the last thing
okay so um I'm going to go back to the
assessment again could something like
this be paid for through the assessment
as opposed through the
tax so I originally looked at it a
couple of different ways the state of
Oklahoma as an example used the fees
generated for licensing their Surplus
lines companies and thank goodness
there's only five minutes left because
we could go down all sorts of rabbit
holes about some of these things uh so I
looked at whether or not that would be a
viable resource for us but again that's
still general fund I appreciate uh we
only take in as a state about $30 to
$40,000 in Surplus lines registration
fees not
really not really a lot for for the
program
um so if you wanted us to
so we do separately assess companies for
certain things so for example uh our
reinsurance uh mechanism for our
individual Market that's a separate
assessment um what's the other big
assessment we do for getting one of them
we can do separate assessments but we
would need statutory authority to do
that yeah I guess I'm just sort of
zeroed in on the fact that you put to
you sent 2.6 million back to the
insurance company so I was just
wondering if there was some money there
that could have been used to fund I mean
so we would need statutory flexibility
to do that I see yeah I mean because
that's another because that's not gen
not going back to the general fund right
the assessment money
anyway um and to the extent it helps to
keep uh premiums down in any way in the
state anyway it's just something I was
pondering it I appreciate the thought
representative let me look into that a
little bit I'm I'm absolutely willing to
explore different options to make this
work all right so what I'm inclined to
do here is is to remove the three
positions that are unfunded and
otherwise keep it the no no other
changes what do people think about that
that sound good okay so should we have a
show of hands on doing
that make a yeah so we'll make a motion
to he's going to get us the three
position numbers we'll take those out at
the bottom of house bill one right and
then but otherwise leave the numbers the
same
yeah right from 88 to 85 yeah I'll
second your motion okay and show hands
have a discussion oh you want discussion
okay okay sure go
ahead well it's just coming
forward those unfunded positions can't
get funded if they if they have more
money they'd have to come back for more
positions they affect the
G not this year but but oh how do they
affect the general fund no it doesn't
but it affects the cost of
insurance which everybody
pays I will get you those numbers before
the end of the day Mr chairman all right
all right so are you ready for a vote is
that right okay all those in
favor all right unanimous thank you all
right thank you commissioner thank you
all should you need anything else from
me please do let me know thank you all
let's talk more let's talk
more
so House Bill 297 we had it as a
non-gain amendment to a separate piece
of legislation Because by the time the
legislative leadership had asked us to
go that route and not go the house bill
2 route which initially made sense to me
because of the budgetary impact we had
the filing period for legislation had
closed so we brought it in as a non-gain
Amendment we had a separate hearing on
it
representative hunt and the house
Commerce Committee are working on
it 297 yes thank
you oh
yeah so representative hunt sends every
bill that comes before that committee to
subcommittee and so we're waiting for
the subcommittee to be uh to meet we'll
bring that
up yep one way or the other it's going
to come to you so we'll have if it gets
over
so one way or the other we'll talk about
it again thank you all
kind we'll make
sure we want we want we want their exper
thank you thank you very much appreciate
that sure abely
are
you good I'm
sure
for
e e
all right so we will welcome
Commissioner of um Department of
Employment Security and uh please
introduce yourself sure um Mr chairman
committee members George kadas
Commissioner of Employment Security to
my to my right Deputy Commissioner Rich
lers and to my left the business
administrator Jill ruels
could you hear me okay or no no you need
to be
closer right how's this better yeah
sorry about that uh commissioner George
katus Deputy Commissioner Rich LS to my
right and business administrator Jill
reels to my left welcome all
right
so um yeah why don't we just go through
this slide
okay um so we have no state general
funds the majority of our non-matching
uh federal funds comes from
usdol uh the banian budget is based on
the continuation of core program
services employment services
unemployment insurance and labor market
information um our our draw down has not
been interrupted uh all programs are
being reviewed to determine any
potential conflicts with executive
orders but to date none of our none of
our funding none of the draw down has
been affected uh without these Grant
dollars we would not be able to
administer these programs at least to
the extent that we currently do the
department also receives supplemental
funding from New Hampshire businesses a
0.2% set aside of employer paid State
unemployment taxes fill the gap for
administering these programs these
employer taxes also provide 6 million
annually for the training fund
administered in connection with the job
training fund uh without these employer
taxes the state could not maintain six
of the 12 New Hampshire Works offices
located throughout the state all 12
offices offer a variety of services to
claimants job Seekers and employers uh
Personnel Services and benefit costs
comprise the largest part of our budget
61% when unemployment claims increase
additional Federal funding based on
workloads and excess of our budget
workload loads count
uh growing economy and a low
unemployment rate results in decreased
Federal funding our full-time staff is
282 the highest Staffing we had was
reached during the pandemic was the
equivalent of 355 in April of 2020
during the pandemic um the office was we
we basically were not able to add staff
because uh Friday everything was fine
Monday everything went off the cliff so
basically all staff at Employment
Security was working 7 days a week uh
from from the start of the pandemic
through the end of August uh because
like I said I mean Friday everything was
fine we had no time to train anybody we
had to just take on the brunt of it and
thanks to our staff and additional
volunteers from other state agencies as
well as the National Guard we were able
to put the plan together in order to
assist the number of people that we did
uh um so just a quick question sure you
have 293 authorized positions so so 11
are vacant is that it pardon me I'm
sorry there are 293 authorized positions
so 11 are vacant because you said you
have 282 right now yeah we've got our
vacancy um there are actually more
vacancies fulltime permanent vacancies
the 282 includes some full-time
temporary positions as well oh okay so
how many full-time permanent our vac um
I believe about 30 at this point wow
okay go ahead we were 14 or so in
recruitment Mr chairman what was the
question there which number were you
looking for how many vacant positions
you have out of this 293 I see yeah so
about about 30 uh 14 of them are
actively being recruited um we are um in
the process of seeking approval from the
governor with the hiring freeze uh we
were being a little bit cautious because
of our Reliance on federal funding we
wanted to see uh what the federal
government was going to be doing with
some of those programs before we
proceeded to hire to fill some of those
positions are you spending a lot on
overtime or Temporaries or something
else no um right now overtime um is low
by our standards uh uh claim volume
um is low we're back below where we were
uh pre pandemic levels so um uh you know
when when claim volume is low um appeals
are low um it kind of filters its way
through the whole work stream so uh not
as much overtime right now not nearly
what we were doing when we were a 247
operation during the pandemic so what
are you going to do with the 14 new
people um so those were positions that
were filled um they were filled uh they
were needed uh they were roles they were
um adjudicating claims they were on the
the front lines in the local offices
providing service greeting people when
they come in uh those positions need to
be filled um right now existing so that
would reduce waiting time in the offices
correct uh you know like right now our
uh front desk person for our Portsmith
in the Hampshire Works office um that
position is vacant it the person left
that to go to a different job so right
now our manager is trying to do that and
do about eight other things as well well
so it's that's a type of position that
we need to fill thank you all right go
ahead okay and U um so the um uh the
pandemic payout uh during during the
pandemic we paid out over $2 billion in
federal and state unemployment benefits
to over
175,000 workers which was more money and
more people paid than the prior decade
combined uh doit represents 12% of our
budget and supports 23.2 full-time do
positions of which 16 are embedded in
within
nags uh unemployment insurance program
uh software equipment and uh equipment
related maintenance represents 10% the
job training fund uh is $6 million and
that's 10% of our budget to and that
supports both employers and job Seekers
uh the general operating expenses is 7%
which covers uh postage utilities
Building
Maintenance uh and uh also assistance
payments under the dislocated worker
program that we administer by mou with
uh
Bea uh the New Hampshire employment
security job fars last year we did 65
job fears which was a combination of
in-person job fars and virtual job fars
in in partnership with Bea in the
community college uh we do employment
recruitment events within all our
offices uh the state labor exchange uh
the employers are able to recruit for
open positions and job candidates search
for work we also have a New Hampshire
Job portal which is simple and quick
recruitment portal for candidates to
quickly connect with hiring employers uh
the job training fund which has been
with us since
2019 uh and uh the employer taxes were
able to provide Workforce and invest
work invest New Hampshire 50%
reimbursement to all New Hampshire
employers for costs associated with
developing training to existing workers
the work now New Hampshire uh financial
support and job Readiness for
individuals in Medicaid medic Medicaid
expansion tanif and snap and the work
ready on New Hampshire program uh which
the community colleges provide job
Readiness training and professional
skill enhancement for the New Hampshire
residents since 2019
we have spent 6.8 million among
45 work invest grants to support New
Hampshire employers 6.2 million work now
in New Hampshire to assist individuals
to prepare and secure employment and 3.6
million for work ready uh New Hampshire
program administered by the Community
College uh managing the Unemployment uh
so you know the biggest part for Ross 2
is trying to get people that have lost
employment no fault of their own back
into the workforce and to get them back
as quickly as possible either through
training programs that they might need
or to assist them to find new employment
opportunities So currently the
unemployment trust fund is at
38.5 million which is close to 100
million more than prior to the P
pandemic um obviously the the higher the
claim volume uh that makes an impact on
the trust fund and right now we're
currently experiencing low un CLA low
unemployment claim volume uh we've had
19% growth which was another 9,000
registered employment establishments
since prior to the pandemic the
workforce growth is 4.5% which is 25,000
additional drops since before the
pandemic uh the trust fund had received
109 million in pandemic funding uh
through the cares act fund
uh in order to build up because there
were a significant number of States
during the pandemic uh that basically uh
ran out of money to pay unemployment
claims and had to borrow money from the
feds uh the lowest average
unemployment tax rate we've had in 30
years and it's the lowest uh third
lowest tax burden in the country um not
a uh budget related item but this brings
up something I wanted to talk to you
about sure um the tax Foundation puts
out this data that rates all the states
on
their uh you know how friendly they are
on taxes or something like that and New
Hampshire believe it or not is somewhere
in the middle you know and in particular
they rate US like 26th in this area in
unemployment tax when we're like the
third best right so have you ever talked
to those guys about their methodology
you know cuz that that is just
ridiculous in my opinion um so it's a
it's an interesting topic and it's one
of those where the tax foundation and
employment security just had to agree to
disagree um the reason why they don't
particularly like the um unemployment
tax situation in New Hampshire is
because there's potential for tax rates
to change quarter by quarter uh they uh
place a high value on on
predictability um and so they don't
think that is a good thing um
despite the fact that the only uh change
mechanisms in statute now are to reduce
your tax rate so even though that change
is a uh positive for the employer as
their tax rate is going down they still
don't like it because it can change um
change when it when it comes to
unemployment tax uh change is a good
thing you don't want to lock yourself in
uh to a long period of time with a rate
that might not be sufficient to support
the trust fund uh with the claim volume
coming in and you certainly don't want
to over tax longer than you need to when
claim volume is low like it currently is
so as the commissioner had mentioned um
a the uh the average private sector tax
rate in New Hampshire right now is
61% they pay that on the first $14,000
in annual wages per employee that comes
out to about
$85 per employee uh that's a third of
the uh tax burden um compared to the
national average um less than a third of
what employers pay in Massachusetts
right now um so New Hampshire is an
outlier in the Northeast um and I think
we will continue to agree to disagree
with the tax Foundation um unless the
unless the legislature that sets policy
changes those solvency mechanisms and um
um in the past the legislator has very
much liked those fund balance reductions
that reduce right so the way I
understand it is it could go down four
times a year but it can only go up once
a year is it could go down three times a
year depending on because you have three
different levels of reduction um the
state used to have uh search charges
that could get added to an employer's
rate uh those got removed in the 2021
reform so that's why I said now the only
the only way it can move is with a fund
balance reduction lower ing you from
your earned rate so maybe it worth for
you or me to make a call to those guys
and maybe they don't know I would I
would love to have another conversation
with them we we did try uh several times
before the pandemic and uh we weren't
getting anywhere but um more than happy
to try to talk with them again okay
thank you go ahead yeah the only other
piece that I had to mention was it's not
a budget related item but we also
partner with administrative services in
administering the voluntary uh Paid
Family Medical Leave Act so we have
there's paid coverage currently for
24,000 New Hampshire workers and it's
available for all New Hampshire
employers and New Hampshire
workers and with that I'll end our
presentation yeah tell me more about
that one um The Family and Medical Leave
Act how much money is
involved um so um when the uh Paid
Family Leave program was passed in
21 um the the statute tasked
administrative services and employment
security with operationalizing the
program a big part of that was um
procuring Administration and the risk
associated with the Paid Family Leave
benefits so uh we did a competitive
procurement MetLife won that contract
they're currently under contract with
the state uh through through uh the end
of
2029 uh so they um they fully administer
the program they fully ensure it meaning
they take on the risk um I know um admin
services with uh commissioner Arling
housee and Deputy Commissioner Keen uh
they have they U as part of their budget
they have the associated State cost for
um uh the state as an employer provides
this coverage to the State Workforce
course um at at the employer's expense
um I think that um is around a $1.2
million cost uh to provide that
additional paid benefit for the
employees um there are other costs uh
that that I would allow edmin services
to talk to um the statute required the
state to do advertising for the program
so the state currently does that um and
uh does uh social media radio television
um Billboards uh to try to help spread U
awareness to employers so they know they
have that option individuals so they
know they have that option um so um a
lot of that with with our role a lot of
it is going out to Chambers uh going out
to different associations and employer
groups and helping explain the program
and answer questions is this program in
your budget no the the only portion of
it that's in our budget is the uh
portion of benefits for our employees um
but the the administrative cost
associated with uh the advertising and
the uh consultant that the state has to
assist with Administration uh that is an
administrative Services budget got all
right thank
you um I believe it was initially
budgeted at 1.9 million
um um well the
program the the cost for the state
portion is that 1.2 million but you have
another
14,000 uh private sector private and
public non-state workers who have the
coverage you have another 1,400
individuals that have purchased it on
their own so the the state coverage
which the state as an employer pays for
um that's a a portion of the pool of of
people that have it um the advertising I
think I want to say that the actual
spend on that was around $700,000
a year um and I know that admin Services
um they can speak to that portion as
they administer that as part of their
budget so so in what sense are you guys
involved um so we we partnered with them
on standing up the program we also have
a statutory role to administer um there
is a fund a dedicated fund that is
created to manage the risk associated
with the individual pool so New
Hampshire um is the only state that
actually allows individual workers to
purchase their own coverage if their
employer doesn't provide it and so that
by by its nature is a very risky pool of
individuals for an insurance product um
so the legislature created a a mechanism
so that all of the insurance premium tax
that is paid by uh metti on the policies
that are sold to all these employers ERS
that insurance premium tax goes into a
dedicated fund for which MetLife can
have access to if they are able to show
a risk of um essentially being in the
negative on the whole program um so we
have those dollars those insurance
premium dollars um they um they come in
through the Department of Insurance like
insurance premium tax on other products
and they're dedicated so they can only
be used to to provide that risk
mitigator to metti if they come in and
show us that hey this past year uh we
took in this amount in premium across
all of the Paid Family Leave products we
paid out this amount in benefits
therefore we feel we're Justified for
the the money that's in that that
dedicated fund for that um that risk uh
pool that that we manage so we're only
allowed to pay it out if they
demonstrate that to us um to the to uh
right now um the program has been up and
running 2023 was the first year uh so
we're into our third year uh we have not
paid any dollars from that fund to
MetLife as of yet uh whether or not
they're going to be seeking payment
anytime soon I don't know but uh that
has been untouched is this the kind of
program where someone can sign up for it
once a year during open enrollment and
not not any time they want is it for the
individuals so an employer can sponsor
coverage at any time during the year
individuals who don't have coverage
through their employer they have a
60-day open enrollment period that goes
from December 1st to January 29th every
year um so that there's a lot of
advertising that's done in that to to
build awareness uh we just finished an
open enrollment we had a thousand people
submit applications we're now at about
1,00 workers enrolled in that uh about
75% of them are women 60 % under the age
of 45 and big surprise here 80% of those
people are using that leave to bond with
newborn children uh so uh for those
workers those those people they don't
have the coverage uh from their employer
so it's a an important tool for them all
right representative mons you you
mentioned a contract with metti um
what's the term of that contract yeah um
it runs till the end of 2029 uh with
with a um a 2-year renewal and are there
any termination
Provisions um there are standard
termination Provisions if they fail to
deliver uh the services that they're
required to under the contract for
instance they are required to provide
both uh the uh coverage available to all
New Hampshire employers uh to purchase
that it's individually underwritten for
each employer depending upon their
demographic but they're also required to
administer the individual pool so they
have to provide that coverage as well if
they fail to do that we could terminate
but it's other than that it's standard
termination Provisions in that what is
there would the state have an obligation
if the state chose to to terminate the
pro the program and terminate the
contract is there an obligation that we
would have to pay um that would be a
question for the Department of Justice
um uh as they would handle those
questions but U if we were to terminate
it for a reason that's not an allowable
reason under the contract then there
would be risk for the state okay thank
representative Griff and then
representative evil yeah thank
you I've I've got a couple of questions
one is how many physical locations do
you have and and uh can claims be made
at all those locations yes claims could
be made at all and we've got 12 physical
locations plus two
satellites we operate as well and my
next question is it looks like you got
23 point something equivalent
um uh do
it and um I'm wondering what what they
do is is it a new system or or has the
system been in place a while it seems
like a lot of people to me for to run a
relatively simple system I would think
um so the um unemployment benefit system
itself is a fairly complic licated
system so individuals it's you know it's
it's an online system so individuals can
file from anywhere both their initial
claim their continued claims our staff
that review those claims to make sure
individuals are eligible they do all of
that adjudication work within the system
so that's that's our biggest most
complicated it system um and the
department of Information Technology
they have uh managed the hardware
associated with that and the production
environment associated with that
together with our other systems our tax
related systems and our wage system um
right now all of those systems operate
from an on premise data center that's
right here in conquer um there there is
a plan that we have been working on to
bring at least the unemployment system
itself to the cloud taking advantage of
some other Technologies um that will
reduce our doit footprint in terms of uh
the number of uh database administrators
that will need and other types of roles
uh people that uh we have a uh a a batch
process that occurs uh five nights a
week that needs people um in order to
make sure batch runs and that claims get
updated and paid that next morning those
types of processes will go away once we
go to the cloud so there's an an
undetermined um amount of reduced
spending and reduced FTE from doit that
we will U be looking at for our new
reality once we do make it to the cloud
uh so that will be that will be
something that will be changing and we
very much want to get out of U managing
our own data center it's a it's a
headache for us that we're we're ready
to get away from and if what what is the
timable for that to happen uh for the
the cloud migration will be occurring
during this calendar year um is our is
our goal um there's some Federal
modernization money uh that the
department was awarded um with along
with 18 other states it was a
competitive uh procurement uh
essentially process within the US
Department of Labor um so some of that
will need to uh be further accept and
expend down the road once uh those
dollars are finalized with USD but it
will it will essentially be paid for uh
with one-time modernization money from
the federal government uh for that
migration to the cloud and and initial
Administration cost all right
representative Ms then representative
eil and then we'll have to stop okay
thank you um does the um does the trust
fund have a investment manager and is
there an investment
policy um so the trust fund dollars are
that you see there uh with right around
390 million those are New Hampshire's
dollars to pay out benefits but it does
not sit with New Hampshire so it sits
with the US treas treasury um they pay
they do that for every state so it's all
each State's unemployment compensation
trust fund sits with the US Treasury uh
they do pay us quarterly interest on
that at a uh rate that um uh
administrator Revels uh can speak to uh
but we do get credited for that interest
we draw down uh from those dollars into
our local account here that sits with
Citizens Bank out of which all of the
benefits get paid we do that on a weekly
basis um and then dollars as they come
in from employers for the tax payments
those dollars then flow through our
citizens account to our trust fund
account in Washington so we don't manage
those dollars they get managed for us by
the federal government as they do with
all other states then the um the the
federal the federal the federal funds
that we get um is that a separate is
that a separate Revenue stream I mean is
that that's not going into the revolving
fund and then coming out correct those
the the administrative dollars that we
get uh for the unemployment program for
the um labor market uh information
programs in for our Reemployment
programs those are all administrative
grants that those come in separately we
draw down from those separately uh they
do not touch the dollars that are in the
uh trust
fund all right representative evil um I
was going to ask a question similar to
that but as far as the interest that's
credited back that you were talking
about from the federal government does
that go into the fund or how is so it's
reinvested it goes into the trust fund
yes okay and then the other just a very
quick comment um I have a friend whose
uh husband is dying of Parkinson's
disease and their son was able to Avail
themselves of this program they um work
for they he works for a private employer
in the North country and I can't uh say
how much the family appreciated being
able to participate in this program for
thanks for your part in it great to
hear all right um unfortunately we've
run out of time and I don't I'm not sure
that we've run out of questions so we
may either ask you some more offline or
ask you back at some point uh before the
end of this process all right thank you
thank you very much thank you thank you
all right and we are now going to the
judicial Council which is on page 510 so
it's the very next
page if they're
here which I guess
[Laughter]
not maybe we're not going to
the okay thank
you I guess so
have to ad not have very Clos I didn't
realize all those
goodies yeah they always
are Revenue yeah
yeah a
skiing I guess so
that's all
right e
thank thank
you all right well thank you for coming
and um before you introduce yourself um
I would just want to say this is one of
seems like one of the most efficient
things I see in house bill one in the
sense that they managed to spend $40
million a year with three
employees so I don't know how they do it
but you're going to explain and um and
maybe you can talk about in particular
kind of the groupings of the of the
different activities because when we
look through the budget we see assigned
Council and judicial Council and
guardian at light them Etc so you can
group them that way thank
you thank you good afternoon my name is
Jay Bucky I am the executive director of
the judicial Council thank you for this
opportunity to discuss the council's
role and
budget first I would like to review the
responsibilities of the council
although as you mentioned the agency
only has three full-time employees the
work of the council and the agencies it
supports touch the lives of tens of
thousands of New Hampshire residents
across the state every year the council
was created by Statute in 1946 to serve
as a disinterested forum for the
discussion and presentation of ideas
about how to improve the delivery of
Justice in our state the council is made
up of EX official members and appointees
of the Supreme Court and governor and
Council the council self meets at least
four times per year and makes
recommendations related to improving the
implementation of Justice in the state
over time the council has also become
tasked with payment and oversight
responsibilities the agency is staffed
by three full-time employees and over
oversees the Indigent defense system for
both criminal and civil
matters in criminal cases the council
provides services through the following
means the New Hampshire public defender
first the New Hampshire public defender
serves as the state's primary means of
providing representation to Indigent
criminal defendants handling
approximately 85% of all Indigent
criminal representation in the state
through its 10 offices and approximately
130 attorneys the public defender
handles most felonies filed in the
entire
State and of course many misdemeanors
and other serious crimes as well when a
public defender is not available a case
must be handled by a contract attorney
these are attorneys who provide ined
defense services on a fixed fee basis if
a contract attorney is not available
then the case goes to a sign counsel
these are attorneys in private practice
who are appointed to represent the
accused on an hourly basis by Statute
any juvenile case that cannot be handled
by the New Hampshire public defender
must be handled by ass signed
Council the council also funds Services
other than Council these are Court
approved requests made by criminal
defendants for forensic psychiatric
interpretive and other Services required
to ensure an adequate defense for the
Indigent
accused in civil cases the council
provides services through Guardians at
lium or gal's for children these are
appointed by the courts to represent the
best interests of neglected and abused
children the council does this through a
partnership with Casa of New Hampshire
Casa accepts appointments as guardians
of lightam in the first instance Again
by Statute and abuse neglect cases
Statewide the council must pay for
private gal when Casa is unavailable to
accept a case the council also pays for
attorneys for parents in abusing neglect
cases and termination of parental rights
cases who are at risk of losing legal
rights to their children and attorneys
for children who are in placement or at
risk of in placement who are otherwise
appointed by a judge in an abuse neglect
or termination of par parental rights
proceeding in Probate Court the council
pays for guardianships for incapacitated
adults and minors and representation in
Supreme Court appeals from any of the
case types that I've mentioned the
council also provides funding for civil
Legal Services through New Hampshire
legal
assistance most people have never heard
of the judicial Council and it is
confusingly named because although we're
called the judicial Council we are not
in fact part of the judicial branch we
are uh an executive branch agency um
however despite not being well known the
work has a remarkable scope and impact
across the state for example in any
given court on any given day there are
likely to be several attorneys doing
work supported by the judicial Council
in a single Courthouse there could be a
public defender representing a client on
trial in the next an attorney advocating
for a parent while in the same hearing
AA Guardian ad lium could be testifying
on behalf of the child in their best
interest and down the hall from that
hearing there could be a pargal from New
Hampshire Legal Assistant speaking on
behalf of a victim of domestic violence
the work of all these attorneys
Guardians at Liam and the organizations
is vital to the administration of
justice in the state the impact of the
work spans
Generations I would like to take this
opportunity to address what is the most
pressing issue in the current budget and
that is inadequate funding of the New
Hampshire public defender for decades
the state has relied upon the public
defender to provide Indigent defense
Services throughout the state as I
mentioned earlier the public defender
provides trial level advocacy Services
appellate services and administrative
and Training Services for the majority
of indent defense cases in the last few
years the public defender has be has
come under considerable strain cases
have become more complex and case loads
have become and stay too high I've
outlined some of the factors leading to
these issues in the handout they include
the increased complexity of each case
longer case periods and increased
expectations related to evaluations and
treatment case loads are set forth in
the public defender contract generally
public defenders are supposed to have no
more than 70 cases at any given time
that's a mix of felonies misdemeanors
and other case types such as
delinquencies sentence related cases
violation violations of
probation most attorneys in at the
public defender now greatly exceed that
70 case limit some attorneys have over a
cases the high case load combined with
relatively low paid compared to other uh
offices and other public defender
offices has caused more and more
attorneys to leave the public fender for
other
opportunities this attrition has not
only led to high turnover among new
attorneys but has led to a lack of the
experienced attorneys the program allies
upon to handle more difficult
cases this attrition has also left
certain offices extremely short staffed
for example the Littleton office was
covers several courts in the North
Country Now only has two attorneys it
should have four that has required to
start Closing Services to certain courts
leaving the judicial Council to find
other attorneys likewise why a Sullivan
County public defender now only has two
of the four attorneys it
requires the increases in the public
defender budget that the council has
recommended are aimed most importantly
at increasing Staffing levels to bring
down case
loads the increases are also aimed at
raising salaries for public defenders
particularly at the lower end the
current starting salary at nhpd is lower
than at any prosecutor's office in the
state and lower than any other public
defender in New
England as outlined in the chart on page
six of the handout attrition at the
public defender has rapidly increased in
the last few years in the current fiscal
year the attrition rate just until the
end of January has already been 14% of
all the
attorneys because the public defender is
a nonprofit that contracts on a biannual
basis it is vital that the program has
an accurate budget upfront so that it
can plan appropriately for future hiring
and expenditures
the state is obligated constitutionally
to provide representation regardless of
whether the public defender can take a
case when the public defender is
unavailable the council must then pay
either a signed or contract councel to
take these cases using Pay paying for
Council by each either of these methods
increases costs so ultimately if there's
not a public defender available the cost
increases to the state when the council
has to pay for those
methods there's also a shortage of
attorneys willing to take take cases in
more rural areas in more rural parts of
the state this can lead to Long delays
in finding
attorneys when the judicial Council must
locate private Council to take cases
this can easily overwhelm the number of
attorneys who are available in a given
area to take cases this leads to a
backlog of defendants who do not have
lawyers this includes defendants who are
incarcerated I have seen cases in my
time with the judicial Council when it
is taken over 6 weeks to find counsel
for an incarcerated person at one point
there were over 40 incar people awaiting
Council and many of those people were
waiting for
weeks lengthy detention without Council
not only invites litigation against the
state for constitutional violations but
causes delays for courts victims and the
administration of justice cases simply
cannot proceed without Council when it
is constitutionally
required in short adequately funding the
public defender not only ensures that
the state meets its constitutional
obligations but it is also more cost
effective in the long run
the next priority I'd like to discuss is
the agency itself the agency has a broad
mandate and a budget of close to $40
million and it only has a full full-time
staff of three as it stands currently
the agency staff struggle to keep up
with the increase in bills submitted to
the agency these bills must be reviewed
for accuracy and the staff of the agency
routinely find and correct issues with
complex complex attorney and vendor
bills that are submitted mostly in paper
form after review
currently every single attorney invoice
expert Bill and other expense must be
manually reviewed and approved by me and
there are over 8,000 a year as noted by
the recent LBA audit an additional
financial position would Aid in
financial oversight and improve
Financial processes at the
council I would next like to mention the
budget lines for assigned Council
guardians of lium and contract Council
because of increasing case complexity
increasing payment responsibilities for
children and increased rates these bills
are virtually certain to increase future
years the judicial Council will likely
need to request additional funding for
these
lines finally the council strongly
supports the continued funding of both
Casa and New Hampshire legal assistance
Casa provides a great service to New
Hampshire's children at significant
savings to the state a casa Advocate is
a volunteer who advocates for a child's
best interest in court Casa trains these
children excuse me trains these
volunteers and also provides legal
support to their volunteers by
partnering with Casa the state gains a
tremendous amount of volunteer
assistance in taking these cases which
also saves the state money New Hampshire
legal assistance is also a vital source
of services for domestic violence
survivors veterans the disabled and all
who would otherwise lack access to Legal
Services New Hampshire legal assistance
has been a leader in successfully
piloting the use of par professionals
who can advocate for victims of domestic
violence in court when they would
otherwise not have
representation the work that New
Hampshire Legal Assistant does also
recoups significant amounts of money for
the state by obtaining Federal benefits
for New Hampshire citizens that they are
entitled to for every dollar spent on
New Hampshire legal assistance it
returns up to four times that in
benefits to New Hampshire citizens I
have had the opportunity in my time at
the council to view both Kasa Advocates
and New Hampshire legal assistance
attorneys in action they are talented
effective and
efficient thank you for the opportunity
to speak today I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you questions from the
committee representative
leishman thank you Mr chairman uh
welcome good to see you as
always so I'm looking on page three of
your document on the top you've got the
adjusted Governor's recommended budget
of 28 million then the judicial councel
recommendation of 37 million uh as you
know coming before fiscal looking for
additional funds I think two or three
times this last
year um the governor's recommended
budget is about $10 million is less than
what you
proposed um was there hope there in the
governor I can't speak for her that if
you needed additional funds you just
come to fiscal because you have that
ability to do that I I certainly
couldn't speak to thinking of others but
I would I do want to reiterate one point
that I think is important for the public
defenders budget line which is that
because it operates on a contractual
basis it is slightly different in terms
of planning and going back for funding
you the public defender greatly benefits
from having a a known budget upfront
because it needs to make hiring
decisions months in advance other types
of bills that we come that the judicial
Council comes back for for funds such as
a sign Council those bills come in on a
rolling basis whereas the public
defender although it can come back for
additional funds it sign it that is done
through a two-year contract through an
RFP that the public defender bids on
essentially so the difference there is
that for P for planning purposes in
order for the public defender to know
how many attorneys it can hire what the
training is going to be what offices it
can staff having those funds upfront is
tremendously beneficial um and I and
just to clarify the distinction between
what I put in terms of the governor's
budget as as currently written and what
I understand to be perhaps an adjustment
in what was intended um my understanding
was there was an error in the process of
um looking at the judicial council's
budget and we came in lower than had
been intended by the governor's office
by about $2 million thank you thank you
Mr Mr chairman okay other
question no representative
wer how do you determine that someone is
Indigent um that determination is made
by the courts they use a form the clerks
of the courts use a form to determine in
iny that's not made by us is whatever
they write down is is no no doesn't have
to be any investigation or
something there's there is a form that
someone fills out under under oath I
believe and that's looked at by the
clerks the courts then have the ability
to further inquire if they don't find
someone's representations credible do we
ever do any Cay from these
clients not that would go through the
office of Cost Containment uh that
wouldn't be something that judicial
Council has been involved in
historically my understanding is
generally in the past if someone was
found Indigent and qualified for
services there would then be a payment
made through the office of Cost
Containment
because it seems to me when we're
handing out money from the state we
ought to be a little more careful of who
it goes to and who we hire Council for
somebody might be able to afford
it that that may well be uh at this
point the judicial Council I think
perhaps appropriately so we don't make
those determinations you know that
that's something that's made at the
judicial branch level so I don't have
any part in in making those
determinations thank you representative
evil did you well I I I was just
interested to see your reference to the
YDC cases on page nine are you involved
in some of those um lit pieces of
litigation yes that's correct um due to
conflict of interest professional rules
uh you know we actually represent
through the council as a whole um the
council doesn't represent but we fund
the representation of several YDC
defendants so I believe there's one
defendant at the public defender and
then there's other uh who are
represented through different assigned
Council and I can tell you that last
time I looked it was about it was
getting close to about half a million
dollars per year that we had spent just
on those cases between attorneys and
services and that doesn't include
amounts that we would have spent funding
the public defender for their work on
the case as
well do you ever fund the litigant in
these cases the
victims I mean represent them
or probably although it wouldn't be
directly it wouldn't be in the same
context but yes we since we provide
services to New Hampshire Legal
Assistant I'm sure that we would provide
services to those same individuals most
likely but not in the same way if that
makes sense no that doesn't make sense
um I apologize um so the only way I
would know specific people who we
represent is because we pay the bills on
specific dockets and specific defendants
so I could looking at those I can tell
you that yes that's a YDC claimant and
excuse me a YDC defendant um in terms of
repres presenting a victim um that those
Services wouldn't be provided through a
signed Council that would be something
where someone could be represented by
perhaps someone from Hamshire Legal
Assistance or
otherwise okay all right thank you
representative Ms then um I'm I'm not
sure I heard this correctly but I I I
thought I heard you say um I think it
was on
um age8 where you're talking about the
bills and the number of the financial uh
process thing that you have to do yes
that um there was a um a desire or an
interest in having an additional uh body
to do that is that correct yes um I I
don't see any increase in your headcount
are you are you offsetting that
someplace else so I perhaps I'm wrong
but the only recommendation I there's no
recommendation in the in the governor's
budget for that extra person so I I've
asked for the funding but it's not in
the governor's budget that was something
we asked for and our prioritized needs
budget didn't make into the governor's
recommended budget but I'm I'm back here
asking for it it was part of our LBA
audit and I I still think it's
appropriate um it was something that was
pointed out in our audit and I can can
say from firsthand experience that our
agency could certainly use more help and
quite frankly I think it would go a long
way not towards more efficient and
better processing but hopefully um
increasing some efficiencies in the way
we pay for
vendors so um you have on page four a
list of how many cases are opened a year
is this is a similar number closed is
the is the you
know relatively flat in terms of the
ongoing number of cases year to year
or it depends on the year so for example
during um 2020 2020 I think many more
cases were opened than closed there's a
real pause I think that number has been
evening out um but uh it depends on the
year quite frankly so in General is the
number of cases declining or increasing
the number of cases increasing for the
public defender I know I can't speak to
filings overall in the judicial system
but generally speaking the number of
cases that the public defender handles
is going up in the last since
2020 okay is that because there's more
crime or there's more indigence or maybe
some of
both I can't speak to that I can say
there's a few things that determine the
number of cases it could be crime could
be indigence and there's also um quite
frankly how long cases last and what
cases get charged so for example um if
prosecutors charge more types of crimes
that raises the level of cases so it can
be um a lot of these cases there's
prosecutorial discretion a prosecutor in
a case can often bring one charge or
they could bring five and uh even if
those cases ultimately get disposed of
um it would still count as five cases
being opened or even if Char cases later
get dropped so a case is a charge not
not a
defendant depending on General yes okay
so of the say
6,352 felonies how many defendants were
there I I have to go back and look I
don't have that
number and just just a little bit is it
a third is it a half is it a I'd say if
I was guess around 2/3 probably okay so
most people are just charged with one
charge most yes okay gotcha all right
represent of
Griffin thank
you um I'm trying
to reconcile in my mind the office of
the public defender plus you and and how
the revenues work what source of Revenue
does the office of the public defender
have other than you
people virtually none um thank
you but they're not listed in our book
right
as that's a separate organization they
are they're listed as a 1094 that's
their budget line then so we pay um we
pay them on contract basis but we don't
see a 100 employees or something correct
because they're not employees they're
they're it's an independent organization
yes okay very good representative
leash thank you Mr chairman and just
another question for you Jay on page 511
it talks about or mentions legal
services and it's about $4.6 million
spent in 24 and yet what's being
requested under the governor's proposals
of flat $2 million and then I look to U
Legal Services over on page 514 again
it's very lopsided 300 3.2 million for
24 and a flat $2 million for 25 and 26
and
so it appears at least to me based on
historic knowledge you're being
completely underfunded again is that
would that be a fair statement or not
putting you on the
spot I would anticipate we would have to
come back and seek additional funds
throughout the bium that's if the
funding goes forward as currently
proposed okay thanks what fraction of
cases are settled versus go to court V
go to trial over
90% representative e um recognizing that
our revenues are uh very low um I just
want to get back to you had you had a
chart here that
um it's I can't find it it's obviously
more expensive to be hiring contract
attorneys than it would be if you could
have some folks that you could hire you
said the turnover rate was very
high in terms of public defenders or
well I'm sorry I mean there was the S
there was I guess what I'm paralleling
your situation to is what we see with
nursing homes and hospitals where they
have to keep hiring traveling nurses
instead of being able to just hire some
people here it is it's on page six and I
and I guess because my point is because
of your perpetual underfunding
you're actually ending up spending more
money than you would otherwise if we
would fund you appropriately and that's
and that's and then you have to keep
going back to the judicial Council that
is I mean the fiscal that I agree with
that and just going back to the public
defender versus assigned or contract
counsel if we don't have public
defenders um the situation that I see it
playing out currently quite frankly is
um if we have to close
to the judicial Council
um let me just back up even more we have
to pay and provide counil for people
when it's constitutionally required we
don't have a choice and the courts can
directly appoint people as well and they
will because they they're entitled to
counsel um and absolutely as you say the
public defender is the most economical
means and it's not even close especially
when compared to assign Council and that
um because the assigned Council they're
paid hourly contract council is more
economical than assigned Council but we
just simply don't have enough contract
Council willing to accept cases on a
contract basis to make to increase the
number of contract Council the rates
would have to increase by a great deal
and that's something that is something
I'm also happy to discuss but um the
general point is that yes you paying for
the public defender is simply like
paying in essence for wholesale for
Legal Services it's a much cheaper model
than paying you know hourly retail for
ass sign Council and because of this
state of underfunding as you say
basically we've had to rely more and
more on a signed Council which is much
more expensive right and because there's
a constitutional responsibility to
provide the council you don't really
have a choice as to whether the council
will be provided or not is that a
correct statement correct so either way
we're going to
pay correct right I I don't mean that in
a mean way I'm just saying that it from
the Pennywise pound foolish standpoint
sometimes it would be better to pay a
little more up front so we don't have to
pay a lot more
later yes all right thank you who
determines the um starting salary rates
of the public defending councils the
public defender
does and so the public defender does
within the realm of what they can
staff okay so if we added money to the
section it wouldn't necessarily raise
that that number it could go to
more it would likely go towards both so
when the and I to provide a little
context the council itself meets and
votes on the budget so the numbers you
see are a reflection of what the council
recommended
and the the numbers that we set forth
were intended to do two things one
increase Staffing but also increase
salaries um because both of those
factors are a play in the attrition that
we've seen why would a council prefer a
person prefer to be a public defender
rather than a contract councel the
public
defender when it's operating at a
healthy in a healthy way has advantages
um it's more stable um you can you work
out of a certain geographic area there's
training there's you know you don't have
to there's benefits um there a lot of
the logistical aspects you don't have to
worry about the logistical aspects of
running a law firm contract attorneys
you know the money that we spend a lot
of that goes towards overhead for the
person to run their office so if you're
a if you're a similar to being a
prosecutor versus a private attorney you
don't you're just focused on practicing
law and that's the advantage did I see a
hand over here representative L um thank
you for taking my question just to
follow up on on what representative eil
was saying um presumably the only the
only reason it would make sense to under
hire or hire fewer attorneys than you
think you might need is if you think
somehow that the case loads are going to
go
down um have the case have case loads
gone down or are they pretty
consistently at the same level they've
been going up generally okay on a per
attorney basis and that so that would
then suggest that you know the the this
this the the smarter fiscal decision or
the more responsible fiscal decision
would be to to make sure that we hire up
to the appropriate level
yes thank you well I'm going to call
this to a close even though this is a
complicated area and we may uh ask you
back or ask you questions
offline um but we probably shouldn't if
the chief justice is here we shouldn't
leave them standing in the
hallway so thank you very much for
coming thank you for the invitation I'm
certainly happy to provide any further
information later on
yeah
for
e e
all
right
so thank you for coming Mr chief justice
um I I'll just direct the committee um
the pages in house bill one start on 164
and end on
179 and I thought I would start on
179 because this is a kind of a bottom
line thing
so I guess this presentation looks
fairly similar to what we saw earlier is
that the it's it's got some of the S of
all good afternoon Mr chairman and
members that division one um it it has
some of the same content which we tried
to condense but it's focused really on
our budget presentation so let me start
I'll I'll make more of a state a
statement and tell you what our problem
is and and let's look at page
179 right which is the bottom line of
your
budget so
um in this budget you spent in
2024 uh $112
million and you're scheduled to spend
for the next three years including the
current year more like 125 126
Etc um our problem is that um the
governor's budget as a whole
overestimated General funds availability
by more than 10% Like between 10 and
11% and so um going up from
um from what's being spent now to by
this amount you know this is uh 13 12 13
14 million per per year
um is essentially an impossibility for
us we have to go down from this these
125 128 million kind of numbers by
something like
10% um
so two fiscal year 2024 it was just a
year ago so you know we could almost
just agree to be at that level going
forward and and call it a day but that's
our
problem if you see what I mean yeah any
any reaction
so Mr chairman I I just so we're level
set on the same page you started at fy4
actual 104 is that yeah no no I have it
as well yeah so if you're looking at gen
General funds you're right right you're
right I was I was looking at the total
funds you're right General funds
104 um and then going to 120ish 119
120ish right so you're right just
general funds so if you could stay at
the one it's really 105 it's not 104 but
yeah it's 104.9 67 yeah so yeah that's
the level that we could do of General
funds now you know maybe we could do
more but but it's it's very
tough well the way we we built our
budget was off of FY
25 adjusted
authorized and that was
um on this just focusing on General
funds when
and our efficiency budget is at
118 um and uh
so uh I understand where you you have a
different starting point our starting
point was F FY 25 adjusted authorized
and we did go down from there and the
reduction there is uh
3.8% from from adjusted uh FY 25
adjusted authorized to to our efficiency
request
so it looks to us like you're spending
another
15% compared to what you did ex a year
ago right in this current year so let me
let's let me just reorient the committee
to some facts about our budget we are
75% Personnel we are 92% General
funds our Personnel that what's Driven
our increases and i a it Mr chairman has
driven our increases are the following
things first two years ago I came to
this committee your counterparts in the
Senate and I
presented I presented the results of our
way to case load
study and this was a study conducted
over a period of year a year by a
national group The National Center for
state courts and they concluded that we
needed both additional judicial
resources and additional staff resources
in response the committee agreed to our
recommendation of seven additional
circuit judges one additional Supreme uh
Superior Court judge and about
35 additional staff and that was based
on on this and um I do I do remember I
think chairman wer you
I remember this very clearly you were
very appreciative that we had actual
data to back us
up Personnel are
expensive uh we had a 10% Coler so
that's that's Factor number one factor
number two 10%
Cola then a 2%
Cola and those colas Drive our benefits
particularly judicial retirement they
drive the benefits
third Factor
benefits this year Dental's gone up
6% HMO
177% POS
32% so just for benefits in fiscal 26
it's a $3.2 million
increase factor
four uh the legislature um asked us to
take on the responsibility fiscal
responsib ability of transferring
prisoners it had previously been with
the Department of administrative
services and we absorbed those costs
it's about $800,000 a year so those are
the those are the primary factors that
that that you're seeing that are driving
the U increase that you note Mr
chairman that that those same Dynamics
create a problem for us because we are
75%
personnel and and I've told the chair uh
privately and I'll tell you now we did
our very very best to avoid any layoffs
in our
system uh and that is that is how we
constructed our efficiency budget the
bottom
line uh let let me talk more
specifically of the points you just
mentioned so the 10% Cola would already
be in fiscal year 2024
correct yes okay so it's already in that
105 million but the 2% is not right the
2% is later and obviously the benefits
costing more that's later and um and
probably you didn't hire these 43 new
people very much in 2024 right maybe you
got a few but not 20% 20% okay good
correct all right and now about
53% gotcha all
right um now we talked when you were
here earlier about if you had to cut you
would close certain uh cour houses and
this kind of stuff is that in the
governor's budget or
not uh the
governor page nine this might be helpful
um of my slides
so our efficiency budget submission you
can see is the Top Line there 118 in the
first year 120 in the
2 uh the
governor's uh general fund Target is 116
milon 356 in the first
year and the same in the second
year the
Delta the Delta is um funds associated
with House Bill 318 which is the
so-called bail
bill um and the cost associated with
that it's about $1.8
million of that about $1.2 million is
the legislator's directive for the uh
judicial branch to pay bail
Commissioners and the remainder is the
implementation of the magistrates their
their salaries and costs associated with
them
okay thank you so I think I saw that 1.8
million somewhere in here
right that
[Music]
was it was like a new new
thing
um
yeah
what's 174 no oh yeah right right right
right yeah page
174 those are the where those numbers
come from so they are in the governor's
um budget
here that's in our house bill one I
guess house yep right now um this this
bought I think it was three um
magistrates is that right correct by the
way uh representative eel has to leave
for an earlier appointment she's not
going to this is not being rude I know I
was just going to apologize I need no
disrespect when I jumped up in five
minutes I'm sorry yeah okay um so this
is three magistrates in this in this
budget here yes plus some related staff
I take it right no
ba they oh the bail commission
themselves the big chunk is about 1.2
million for bail commissioner payments
okay gotcha yeah but some of that is
offset by Revenue right so you're
collecting some yeah yeah I think we
build out we're just looking to see how
it goes but I think we've paid out about
100,000 and we've collected back about
13,000 so 13%
okay and I just knowe Mr chairman this
is a new function for us and there are
car costs associated with collecting the
[Music]
revenue yeah that brings up a question
um there's a
bill uh
well no I guess this is not a question
for you I was thinking about there's a
bill to not collect from Indigent people
who use the um judicial Council Services
right because the cost of collection is
greater than the cost of uh uh what they
you know what they get is the same thing
true here are you're spending more than
13,000 to collect that I
mean it's difficult to quantify that
because we have existing staff who are
now doing but yes it is an additional
task that they are now asked to
do okay great all right representative
Ms so on this this sorry thank you m uh
Mr chief justice for taking my question
um so on this this this bail reform line
item so we implemented a new a new
process of handling bail um that
presumably was baked into the FY 24 25
numbers correct I mean there is a
process in place
now there has been a place unless I'm
missing something the the
responsibilities that HB 318 was enacted
last year y okay the responsibilities
assigned to the judicial branch in that
bill are new oh okay so this is this is
this is that it's not what the governor
is hoping to do going forward as I
understand she's she's seeking to change
the actual substance of the bail I
apologize thank
you okay um let me ask about on page
166 uh class class
73 uh grants
non-federal what that all about that's
something that's going way up
166 look at at class
73 grants
non-federal uh it's going from 2.9
Million actual to
4.7 and then later
4.4 so those those are grants associated
with the drug
court so you going to have more drug
court is that the idea okay sorry uh so
in fiscal year 2024 2.9 Million is what
we ended up actually paying out it's
reimbursements to the drug cour programs
in our counties uh fiscal year 2025 is a
budget number so that is the full amount
of appropriation available to contract
out in Grants to the counties that's
very different from what we may end up
reimbursing the counties that's all
you're seeing here and with 26 and 27
based on what we believe we will pay out
not what you know what they may ask to
have contracted but what we will pay out
we reduced our budget a
bit okay but you do so but you're
planning on a third more drug court or
something right because in
reimbursements compared to last year to
24 yes yeah
okay got representative Le
thank you Mr chairman I do have a couple
of questions and and look towards Donna
Raymond as a chief Finance person for
the court obviously there's a lot of
cost increased with House Bill 318 that
the Chief Justice mentioned and the
magistrates there were five magistrates
or three three magistrates could you
point us uh on the budget where that
would show up that
yes so it's on page
174 so kind of second half of the page
if you look at um where it says 010
Personnel yep those are the salaries for
the three magistrates there it is and
then their their benefits are in class
60 so obviously if I could further Mr
chairman obviously that's a significant
increase of almost $2 million a year to
your budget just to satisfy what we
tried to do with bail reform last year I
do have another concern if I could
continue Mr chairman go ahead it's um
I'm a little concerned with the
discussion we had when you were here
before about the possibility of closing
uh especially the Claremont district
court or Circuit Court um Senator Bob
Odell and I back in the one of the worst
uh Economic Times back in 20 2009 went
across the state and tour the um the
courts that had been proposed by I think
chief justice broadrick to close and
there's our report which you'll find in
there it mentions specifically
Claremont and we heard from a number of
people City officials school officials
the place was packed about the closure
of the clar court and I now have heard
from representative cluder who is a
senior
member of that community and I don't
know if claremont's still on your list
or if there's been any discussion about
closing clar further thank you uh for
the question representative uh there's
been further analysis of which cour
houses make the most sense to close and
we have adjusted that and it is in our
presentation um so page uh the
the slide 17
and from a savings perspective and
operational perspective and judge
Christo administrative judge of the
circuit court is here um we've concluded
it makes more sense uh to close hookit
and goof down circuit
courts
okay the other thing I'd like to add Mr
chairman if I could
for the nine terms this being the ninth
term that I've sat on this
division we've always uh in I think good
deference to the court uh accepted your
budget as it been brought forward and
because obviously you're a branch of
government you probably know better than
the rest of us how to run your branch of
government uh when you met with the
governor and she suggested 4% cut across
the board was she aware of the impact it
would have like closing courts or
reduction of services you mentioned
Security Services would be impacted
which would entail not holding hearings
because you didn't have hearings
officers so any of that discust or yeah
just to
to set the table a little bit our
efficiency budget was based on guidance
from governor cunu and it was submitted
in September of 22 we so we just do the
agency phase we don't do the governor's
phase so it was submitted as we
submitted it in September of uh end of
September of 2024 so our current
governor um inherited if you will what
we had submitted um we in submitting
that
budget uh we were aware of the guidance
that the governor gave to executive
branch
agencies and uh just as it's been
practiced with for division one to pass
on the judicial branch budget the
judicial branch has always tried to be a
responsible partner in state government
and if the executive branch was asked to
make 4% Cuts we we felt obligated to
make our very best effort to do that and
so that is the efficiency budget you've
been
presented we and and the impacts that we
described last time together are a
result of that efficiency budget we did
our very best to be faithful to what the
governor at the time was requesting and
minimizing the impact on our
operations I know representative obber
was never bashful to make
recommendations anyway I I guess I'm
just concerned you know I heard earlier
from uh representative the good
representative from wantt Vernon on an
issue uh we had before a fiscal today
that Justice delayed is Justice denied
and I think SE said it well and another
case but the same thing to me exists
here that if you can't hold hearings
because you don't have security staff
how does that benefit the state as far
as getting feir Justice there's no
question about
it okay that's all I have Mr chairman at
the moment thank you so are you saying
that this stuff on page 17 is in the
governor's 2026 and 27 budget closing
cookit closing G down
you it's in the budget we submitted in
2024 the
governor um traditionally just submits
our budget but is permitted to make uh
comment she did make a comment through
House Bill 2 that's the very second to
last
slide um
and she identified a bottom line
appropriation
uh you'll see there
um so
the and while we're on that I just want
to note for the record um that her
suggested
adjustment should be
corrected and we have been in contact
with her office about this that it um we
were instructed last August that for
fiscal
27 we did not need to include step
increases or health and
benefits um her number that you see here
in
hb2 um
included those and they should be
deducted and that's the strike through
the strike through is ours and it
reflects that
deduction but all right but what I see
in house bill one if I add the two years
is 2
28.3 so it's neither of these numbers
on page 175 Mr chair oh I'm sorry I'm on
Supreme Court my it's uh 238
yeah I see
238 I gotta okay
F
238 looks like
7 yeah okay yeah yeah all right so 238.9
but your
saying with these particular
cuts
no the the difference between our Mr
chairman page
nine the difference between our
submission and her hers is the bail
money $1.8
million in both fiscal years M and then
in fiscal
[Music]
27 in fiscal
27 uh there's a Delta of 2.3 million
associated with step increase in health
and dental benefits that we were advised
to exclude and um and again we were
informed by The Bu by the governor's
office that she agrees with that so that
those are the
two major differences between what she
submitted to you and what we
submitted yeah my problem is we're still
not getting
to all right let's let me ask it this
way um you're adding 43 employees how
many employees did you start with
no so the chair Mr chairman your
question is before
we made the adjustments based on the way
to case load study what was our head
count right at the start of fiscal year
2024 e
you
while we're looking for that I'll ask
another question so page seven says
there are more than 150,000 cases filed
every year how many of those um touch a
judge all of
them yes how how many of the
150,000 touch a judge
yes or do some of
them uh they settle and the judge never
sees it
or sure I I don't I don't think we have
those numbers at some point judicial
staff touch every single one of those
cases staff does Sure Staff does how
many actually resolve prior to a judge
seeing it I I don't think we have those
numbers okay
um if I may just add in there actually
even when it's resolved a judge still
has to review settlement agre so even if
it's result the judge still has to sign
off on may not go to trial hearing but a
judge still okay the reason I'm asking
this is so this makes it look like a
case costs
us
um call it
$9,000 okay right 150,000 cases spending
$120
million right oh I'm
sorry no no no $1,000
right okay n or $900 maybe for a case
well we've been looking at things like
the
btla okay and and they do for them it
cost them like $10,000 a case it cost
you $1,000 a case right so why do we
have them you know what I
mean that's the the theory is we have
things we have btla habb this that and
the other thing because they're cheaper
or quicker or something compared to the
court but if the court can do a case for
$900
right none of them can do a case for
$900 right do you have any any comment
on
that do I have any comment on that we I
I can't comment on btla and their
operations I don't it's beyond my
representative wer yeah I I think
something I asked before but I didn't
get an answer excuse me when was the
last time you increase the filing fees
and you know what was it and and you
know $10 or $20 for each case brings a
million2 million dollars more in that
takes care of a lot of
the amounts we're worried about
so just uh for the record we
we've submitted a report to the Ways and
Means
Committee uh division one I believe
that's in your email I sent that out
yesterday
excuse right last increase it depends on
the fee so that they've been caring at
varying points in time the fees have
been changed so we put in a table so you
can see all of them good so what I'm
seeing is
um increased to
225 up from 180 in
and and this is this is for Supreme
Court so we did one for each court all
right that's for Supreme Court y circuit
this a circuit court 150 didn't say when
they were last increase they have two
versions because they have e filing
so that's I would propose it's time to
increase these filing fees by $20 which
seems to take care of a lot of the costs
that we're they're picking
about so wasn't the filing fee and
general maybe this just a civil case
$250 yes two there's 225 here for the
Supreme Court entry I'll let the judges
speak to it but the reality is there are
different fees for kind Cas and they've
been changed at varying times over the
past 20 years so the document that you
have will tell you every single and
presumably criminal cases have no fee
right so is that right yes and and then
if folks are Indigent the fee may be
waved in other cases so how many of the
150,000 cases is a criminal case
70% oh thank you I'm just G to take
out okay so there's over 100,000
criminal cases okay and as I understand
it a case is a crime not a defendant
right so the there there's fewer than
100,000
defendants right because some defendant
might have done this that and the other
thing right is that right and and and
each one's a case yes I remember when we
were looking at the County
attorneys every arrest was at least six
crimes I mean so now you're coming for
and and of course there's always the one
of U attempted to escape you know it
goes down at resisting arrest and almost
every one of them was resisting arrest
and and all this other thing and and and
we said to the to the county attorney
you have so many crimes but you don't
have that many criminals was an average
of about six a piece criminal so yeah
this this is what we're finding is that
correct is that yeah okay each one of
these has to be addressed okay we'll let
you off on these three but we got to
charge you with those two you're going
to
jail you know but but wouldn't all six
be on one procedure in court yeah I
don't think so I think each one of them
is a separate
charge so it looks like the case load is
I think this gentleman would like to
speak why don't you come on now I guess
I shook my head too much yeah yeah so
Mark Howard chief judge of the Superior
Court yes so our case count is based on
docket numbers there might be multiple
charges in one docket number one
defendant might have multiple docket
numbers so each of those docket numbers
needs separate attention for the most
part for the superior Port it's about
70% of our case load that is
dockets um is Criminal so there would be
no file in fso
schedule okay and just to make the point
we don't control what cases are filed
with us that's by the state account okay
or the charging yeah the arresting
officer usually but they might file six
different charges right and then plea
bargain away several and you're guilty
of that one or something like that those
charges are in the same case you know
it's the same core conduct relating to
one case yes and then they might drop a
couple or plead out a couple that's I
understand Goa okay make sure the
records clear on the criminal cases in
the Circuit Court percentage is lower
excuse me Ellen Christo I'm the uh
administrative judge of the Circuit
Court uh so we have approximately uh
about 55,000 of our
131,000 cases a year are criminal cases
and again within that could be multiple
chares all right so say that again
55,000 55,000 we have approximately
131,000 cases a year in all three of
visions and approximately 55,000 are
specifically criminal cases there are
the things that are associated with some
criminal actions like warrants things
like that but specific cases that are
brought it's
approxim okay and the rest are
violations
or the rest would be uh small claes
landlord tenant uh parenting ought to
probate stes trust divorces divorce um
abuse neglect all so that would be all
of our so criminal includes violations
and misdemeanors correct yes as well as
um felonies because we get felonies um
at first instance so we do the felony
arraignments and probable cause hearings
in the circuit court before and if we
find probable C they get bound over to
the security about half of them pay
filing
fees that I would have to I in terms of
the criminal cases no not obviously the
criminal cases don't I I would have to
get those numbers I I don't have an idea
off the top of my head how many actions
they
filing because if if we haven't
increased the filing fees since 2013 and
most of the ones I'm looking at that
would seem ripe or an adjustment with
all the inflations we've had since 2013
and I don't think anybody can argue with
it
if we made a substantial increase in
those and it would take off some of the
burden we're worrying about paying for
the courts I remember back
in 30 years ago lower courts supported
themselves on fines and
fees and I think at the time lower
courts were 16
million and we decided to go
with paying for them under under General
funds
10 years
later we were up to 40,000 then we're
still only getting like 20,000 in fines
and fees because nobody had bothered to
oh it's not our money who cares right so
you know we've got to kind of pay for
the services to some degree and I don't
think anybody can argue with that did
you come up with a total number of
employees yeah so in the 2627 budget
there are 726 full-time equivalent uh
clerical so non-judicial
staff that will include some of the
additional positions for which we
received funding in 2425 not all of them
because we did unfund some of the
positions to meet the governor sununu's
Target okay that's all non-judicial
correct and the judges are uh the
judges we're we're fully
staffed for judges less than 100 77
fulltime judges one part time and
some
77 all right so when you added 35 more
staff due to what we did last year last
time that was only a 5%
increase
yeah
okay um so there was a 5% increase in
staff there was a there was a 2%
increase in salaries and there was a um
some percent increase in
benefits but I guess I'm still having a
hard time getting
to the 15% what what is the total
increase
here yeah
the the 15 or
16% maybe not quite
that all
right other questions yes represent one
thank you Mr chair um I I I just like to
try to understand you know what the
total numbers are I'd just like to try
to understand what the total numbers are
I mean if I if I am reading the the
budget um book that we received on page
179 it shows that for FY
2026 the governor is recommending a
total budget for the for the judicial
branch of15 mil5 588
355 are you you see where I'm
at and and I guess what I'm trying to
understand is is that the number that
you think your budget is for that year
or are you believing that it's a higher
a higher or lower
number well um the there's an adjustment
so if you look at the the line that says
judicial branch 128 million 2459 you see
that yeah and then there's a deduction
basically the 2,
65769 yeah that our budget is 128
245974 but it that
2,657 is transfers from other agencies
so they're trying not to double count
them so because if you said oh I'm G to
give you a million you know agency I'm
agency a I'm gonna give be a million
dollars I have it in my budget of a
million they have it in their budget for
a million double count so but but you're
you're you're in agreement that your bud
what you're asking for what you what you
asked for was 128 245
974 mhm in total not General funds it's
total total
funds the general fund component of that
is the 118
18652 which includes bail reform money
you deduct the bail reform money you get
to Governor's
Target well the bail reform money is
included in that that's correct that's
why I say if you back out the reform
money from the18 million because it's
all general fund money okay we met
Governor sununu's Target that he gave us
okay and then just to come back to
something else we were talking about
earlier that $128 Million number for FY
26 does that include any of the savings
associated with goof closing goof toown
and hookit not goof toown and hookit
Candia and
Claremont okay so this reflects this was
still Candia and Claremont
okay and you should see that reflected
in um accounting unit 1880 class 28 so
it's on page 166 of your budget that
transfer of plant
property okay it's built into those
numbers that we receive from Bureau of
Court facilities okay and then that
number does not include I I was jumping
ahead a little bit in your presentation
there were a number of um prioritized
budget needs that does not that number
does not include any of those things
correct such as and we talked quite a
bit the last time you were here about
security so there's there was a you know
there was a a wish list I guess of about
$900,000 for security that's not in here
correct
okay thank you representative Ms can I
just add something to that I do want to
note just um because you are new to the
committee there is an additional um as
chief justice pointed out there is an
additional footnote in the back of your
budget book where the governor makes an
additional uh reduction of $6 million
over the banum to General funds that is
not reflected in the total numbers that
you just discussed $6 million for the
judicial branch over the banum in
general funds footnotes will get you
every
time
yeah I have a question yes
representative wer so some previous
times we were reviewing the court
system we discovered there were several
circuit courts that were staffed five
days a week and judges were there only
one or two days is that still
exist it does in h in are two of those
places those are the ones we're closing
those are how many more can we close
we're looking to consolidate into other
uh cour houses such as Candia that is
also that same thing so that way it
would be fully staffed all the time so
we were looking for those efficiencies
those those were the only two that were
likely
last that is a more complicated question
because there are other places for
instance in the North country that have
some of those issues but they
geographically really can't consolidate
with another Court Courthouse um so but
these are the two that that look best
candidates for that and actually uh
provided an additional uh approximately
$42,000 a year in savings over Candia
Claremont combination no I I remember
when we um closed the one in plasta that
was that kind of court and you know I
thought oh we'll sell the building and
make money no it became I think the town
owned it so it became a library or
something but are a lot of them like
that that were renting it yeah I almost
about half and half that we own or or
lease and the two that we're proposing
are both leased uh buildings now we save
lease payments so that's good thank you
we have a bill to get rid of Family
Court then replace with mediators is
there Savings in that or not
um I can't speak as to the policy of the
bill but certainly I don't believe
there's any savings uh we already send
every case uh to mediation through the
court
so I can't imagine that there would be
Savings in it but I can't speak to the
specifics of that bill so so family
court is just a subset of circuit court
right it's a division yes it's one of
the division one of the three divisions
of the circuit are there judges assigned
just to that no they're all cross
trained everybody's cross trained and so
intended to be we're sort of general
practitioners and and how many there's
40 something 49 49 Superior Court 49
circuit 23 Superior say that again 49
circuit 23 Superior 23 okay and we've
got drug courts and Veterans courts and
what
else drug courts veterans courts is
there any other special courts mental
health courts mental health
courts those all using the same cour
houses as the circuit courts and the
general
are drug courts circuit
courts
okay
gotcha all
right all right so a question for the
chair I just kind of curious represent
LE U I'm just kind of curious you were
very much involved with the bail reform
as the whole division was last year
you're gut feeling with these proposed
suggested cuts by the governor how it
might impact the work we did last year
for instance on bail
reform I'm sure you have a
thought yeah well I was going to ask
about um magistrates so despite the you
know the the
recent case that made the newspapers
um we generally had the idea that that
magistrates were a good idea because
they're a lot less expensive than um
than judges and
so um would it make sense to have even
more magistrates and fewer judges would
that save
money think I guess you were creating
positions going forward the answer to
that would be yes it clearly magistrates
cost less than judges do um magistrates
can't do all of the same things that
judges do so there's certain constraints
in their uh in what they can do um but I
don't think you could lay off judges
because judges are
appointed um so there's certainly not no
Savings in that but certainly going
forward if there were additional
positions created that would be right
and can a magistrate handle a complete
case or do they have to do something and
then it gets handed off to a judge so uh
in magistrates handle the initial uh
items in a criminal case so for instance
they do bail hearings they can do
arraignments uh and they can do probable
cause hearings so all the preliminary
matters in a criminal case they can also
uh make determinations on warrants
things like that um and so we're using
them in our court houses now to to give
back judge time so that judges can do
other other work um but right now under
the administrative order that is all
that they are authorized to do by both
the legislature and the and the
administrative so it's a subset and only
the preliminary and only
criminal so would it be impossible for
them to do parking tickets and speeding
tickets and all those those kind of
things right now the way the law is yes
it would be impossible the law would
have to change in order for that to
happen Okay I can change the
law that's what I'm here for right I
mean it's so okay I see all right thank
you
um other questions all right well we've
we've had you for an hour and I think
that's probably all I should take um
this is a complicated area and like I
said we we are not very close as far as
I can tell um between what we need and
and what we've got in the book now so um
we are going
to talk study more and and uh
maybe offline talk some more I guess I I
don't really want to take up your time
because you're trying to process 150,000
cases you know so well if I could just
respond of the chair's first question
104 million would
be devastating yeah it would be um I
mean you did it last year right so it's
like but
we
yeah it it'd be hard to get to that
number right I mean if you
had and if I may as well to put fiscal
year 20 25 into perspective um there is
a 5.3% lapse expected we're looking to
meet that so we're looking to lapse
about $7.5 million in general fund so I
would take
the uhuh okay yeah so I would take the
121 you can reduce it by 7.5 but that's
a fairly accurate um estimation of what
we are going to spend with what we have
now okay I see yeah I always think about
it without laps but that that's a good
point uh about 7.5
million we will lapse back in general
funds okay so you expect fiscal year 25
to meet that lapse correct that's
correct okay and we're making up a
significant shareff reimbursement
shortfall with that as well still
meeting our
laps maybe we should start
maybe we should start budgeting you know
real numbers instead of numbers plus
laps
right it just seems like it adds
complication without you
know the death row
jeans people on death row had been
sitting stit out BL jeans
selling okay thank you all right all
well if if we can uh obviously as the
committee goes on we're here to provide
more information and help you come to
the best decision possible under the
circumstances and so please yeah please
reach out yeah it's just you know we
have what we have that's the problem and
thank you very much and we are in a
recession that's the other problem all
right thank you very much Mr chief chief
representative mire representative mire
yes hi yes I'm Nina Gardner and I'm the
chairman of the judicial Council I want
to make sure you got word of the error
that was in the judicial Council budget
oh the governor's office um indicated
there is a a discrepancy between what
they told us and what was put in the
budget I have dou umentation of that
it's very much more helpful in some
senses to us maybe not to you but it
does raise our budget from 39 M from 37
to 39 million the governor had intended
that to be in our budget we are
absolutely going to we need that 39
million probably in 10 more but I want
to make sure you got communication they
said they were let me this give it to
Melissa you
get yes
okay okay that's I want to make sure you
got it I think J mention presentation
that's terribly important to our budget
that's okay so I just want thank you
thank
you
e
e e